joe biden will soon be on his way here
to nashville for the final debate
it'll be the first time we've seen the
democratic nominee since sunday
but is that the right strategy i want to
talk to ohio congressman and biden
surrogate tim ryan wonderful to have you
congressman thank you so much
so the vice president has been prepping
for this debate for the last few days do
you think he is ready
oh no question i think it's going to be
a lot better now with the microphone
situation he's going to be able to
actually
explain his positions around preserving
medicare
and social security and the whole build
back better plan which i think a lot of
americans are going to be very excited
about about bringing manufacturing back
focus
focusing on making things in america
again i think it's going to be good and
he's going to have an opportunity to
actually get that message out so
we're psyched up and ready to go for
this one
so you mentioned the economy i did want
to pull this up we had the new fox poll
last night and in the battleground
states i know you're
of course there from ohio um on the
economy who do you trust better to
handle it
biden versus trump and in your state um
trump definitely is up ahead 52 to 41
tied in michigan um in pennsylvania
trump's up by five and in wisconsin
up by seven um is there something that
the
vice president can do tonight to try to
knock president trump's
numbers down a bit well i think just
continue
his message here in ohio has been look
we need to build back better
working class people were struggling
even before coronavirus
how do we do things that are going to
bring manufacturing back we're going to
build electric vehicles build charging
stations build batteries these are huge
investments
that are going to create millions of
jobs in the united states
and by all accounts biden has a great
plan that all of the economists and
analysts are saying
but he really hasn't been able to make a
debt
he really hasn't been able to make a
dent in the president's numbers on the
economy so far
well i've seen polls that that have had
a neck and neck too i mean you're
talking about a couple polls there but
i've seen
polls that that have have him neck and
neck and here's the kicker
this economy is going nowhere until you
get the virus under control
and i think joe biden's numbers around
who would better that point tonight
virus he has a huge lead against trump
so yeah maybe he has some advantage
there but you're not getting to the
economy until you take care of the virus
and that's why biden's doing well in so
many of these polls
congressman we know that president trump
is going to bring up even if the
moderator doesn't
this these new developments in regards
to hunter biden's emails and he will try
to paint joe biden
as a corrupt person a corrupt politician
and that say that the american people
deserve answers
do you think that joe biden will provide
any answers on this
so far the strategy seems to have been
to dismiss this whole issue
out of hand well it's been dismissed by
two republican-led senate committees so
this is going nowhere i think it just
shows that you know the president
needs to shake this race up in some way
and he's going to say whatever he has to
say
but if you're if you're going back to a
a laptop that was left somewhere that
we don't even really knows who who it
was know who it was
uh or whose it was uh you're really in
the last 10 11 12 days of a campaign for
president you're really
stretching to try to make something
happen there people know joe biden they
know he's not corrupt
uh he's been in office he was the
poorest senator when he came out of the
senate
uh you know it so he they know who he is
that's
well i think that's probably also why
the president will ask yeah
well focus on what he's going to do for
the american people
and stop trying to bring up all these
corruption charges we could bring up a
bunch of corruption charges too but
joe biden well democrats have accused
president trump of all sorts of things
yeah they've accused him of all sorts of
things for a while let me ask you just
one last question though because i do
think this is important not just for
uh the people of ohio but all across
this country
where are you on this coveted relief
bill
would you like to see a deal get done
before the election
i would i think we need to get a deal
done immediately but it can't be a blank
check to the administration
and everyone needs to be included in it
you can't just include
small businesses and leave out people
who are unemployed you can't do just
unemployed and leave out small
businesses we're all american do you
think nancy pelosi has
played this wrong do you think that the
speaker has played this wrong
and dragged it on way too long when you
had some republicans and even the
president saying that they'd be willing
to make a deal well the president has
been all over the board on this thing
depends on the day depends on the tweet
but i think
we'll take his last offer at 2.2
trillion
well if it's 2.2 trillion and it's going
to everybody and it's
it's in every dollar stays in its lane
then i think we should make that deal
but let's be honest the the last two
versions that have come
uh that they were talking about during
the negotiations were basically blank
checks to the administration that they
could spend now they see
fit that's not how we're gonna do this
with the congress governs the president
is a part of that but congress governs
we need to make sure that working-class
people are taking we have eight million
people that have fallen into poverty
i agree with you we have to do more we
take care of everybody
i think and i think well you and i agree
on that and i think a lot more people do
as well um congressman thank you so much